some cruise is absence from the 2023
Oscars drew a few jokes from host Jimmy
Kimmel but really why wasn't he there
considering all those nominations for
top gun Maverick did something upset him
or were there other reasons top gun
Maverick soared into the Oscars with six
nominations but star Tom Cruise wasn't
in attendance to see how well the film
fared on the biggest night of the year
for movies deadline was the first to
confirm that Cruz would not be attending
the 95th Academy Awards because his
commitment to his crafting career forced
him to miss a prestigious Affair
specifically he was filming in Sicily
and the United Kingdom completing his
work on Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part 2. the follow-up to the
first dead reckoning installment set to
release in summer 2023 there were high
hopes attached to that Reckoning part 1.
many hope it will have the same effect
on the box office that top gun Maverick
had when it grows over 1 billion dollars
in 2022. Maverick not only proved to be
the biggest box office draw of the year
but it also earns high-flying scores on
Rotten Tomatoes us on the Oscar's red
carpet Cruiser's Maverick co-star
Charles Parnell said that Cruz was
saving the movie industry while people
are fret Maverick was nominated for best
picture as well as several other honors
namely best adapted screenplay best
sound best film editing best original
song and best visual effects Cruz
himself was nominated in the best
picture category as one of the film's
producers Maverick didn't end up
snagging that award but it did win for
best sound while Tom Cruise's hard at
work delivering another big screen
spectacle Oscar's host Jimmy Kimmel
couldn't tell but point out how the
Superstar skipped the ceremony during
his opening monologue Kimmel called out
the top gun Maverick actor and Avatar
the way of water director James Cameron
for not showing up to the year's biggest
celebration of Cinema despite being the
two most vocal supporters of the
theatrical experience Kimmel quipped the
two guys who insisted we come to the
theater didn't come to the Dolby Theater
okay more than jokingly suggested that
Cruz disguised himself as actor Judd
Hirsch wearing one of those uncanny
masks from Mission Impossible Hirsch
nominated for best supporting actor for
his role in the fablemans laughed along
the host rubs up by pointing out
Cruiser's athletic body in Top Gun
Maverick and try and get into the
actor's renowned faith in Scientology
Kimmel said Tom Cruise with his shirts
off in that Beach football scene L Ron
hubba hubba Crews may not have been at
the Oscars but Lady Gaga certainly was
delivering a mighty and Powerful
rendition of her oscar-nominated track
hold my hand from the Maverick
soundtrack it was previously reported
that Lady Gaga will be skipping the
event due to her commitments to the
Joker sequel Joker Foley are do just
hours before the 2023 Oscars began
variety confirmed that the pop sensation
would take the stage to sing hold my
hand like the film the song received
significant critical Acclaim with
variety calling it an Oscar FrontRunner
early on it was also well received by
fans especially considering the music
video has more than 155 million views on
YouTube as far as honors Go the song has
already received some awards attention
with a nomination from the Grammy Awards
for Best Song written for media that top
gun Maverick soundtrack was also
nominated for best compilation
soundtrack for visual media while it
didn't win either of those accolades nor
the Oscar for best original song Gaga's
stripped down performance was an
unforgettable part of the Academy Awards
telecast so even though Cruz couldn't
make it to the ceremony top gun Maverick
was certainly well represented at
Hollywood's big night
foreign